[Music]
imagine spending an extra five years in
prison just because you didn't know your
sentence was over I spoke up that kind
of [ __ ] happens a lot happened to a
Samoan man are those like rolled over
Dale times so now you could commit
something and you're like out he did the
five years yeah I pre did the five years
roll over years yeah so like commit a
crime that's about five years where it
is up to you to keep track well it
shouldn't be right you probably want you
to be in there longer oh yeah a hundred
percent cuz they make more money on you
yeah okay the way the private not even
just a private but the way the prison
system works right is you for every end
mate it's about 40 to 50 grand per
person a year 62 and if you own a jail
and it these things are privately owned
right wouldn't you want it to be fully
occupied it's like owning a hotel it's
like owning a [ __ ] daycare anything
like you want to maximize it well what
are the cops get out of it for like
filling it up do they get a kickback
there's promotions so you know hitting
numbers you don't get promotions and all
this stuff when you get tickets out like
when you make arrests you're top in the
precinct like you're the top guy cuz you
made so many arrests right and so most
well I know for a fact in Arizona like
most inmates are in there for like
marijuana charges or like drug charges
and they're not you're not talking about
drug dealers you're talking about a dude
like a teenager just [ __ ] getting
pulled over in his car and he has an
ounce of weed that's majority of inmates
in the prison system and people don't
want to [ __ ] believe this [ __ ] right
but then it's [ __ ] up like I mean I
did graffiti and I went through the
public system and they didn't tell me
[ __ ] they're just like alright well
here's your paper go ahead and sign it I
signed it and then all this [ __ ] went
down and then my parents were told by
other people get a [ __ ] lawyer what
are you doing don't use a public
defender like they're just playing a
game
yeah and then our lawyer came in and he
[ __ ] changed everything and so all of
my friends they had to go to juvenile
hall one of my friends was 18 he had to
go to prison
not prison jail which is County minimum
security or whatever and then I was the
only one that got probation because I
had a lawyer who [ __ ] did everything
right and so yeah I wasn't even supposed
to sign it like they denied even read it
I don't even know what it was but it was
in the mission to guilt and that's what
happens to a lot of minority kids are
just if we don't have a lawyer they just
give us papers and they go sign this
okay and you just like whoa you're my
lawyer so I have to sign it because it's
the public defender who told you that
it's a sign it was an admission of guilt
and so for what they do is they give you
the maximum so what ends up happening is
like let's say the maximum drug charge
that you can have was like five years
right most people probably would have
got like one if they fought it or
whatever but let's say like in the state
like where weed is illegal you get five
years on it they're gonna [ __ ] give
you the max because they're hoping that
you stay there for five years and then
you get into a fight or something and
you can extend your stay and it's more
it's super profitable for the jail's to
do it this way but people don't know
that people think that the prison system
is like you do your time you get in
trouble justice [ __ ] that dude it
doesn't work that way
plus with that it's the second you get
basically like tainted jail or whatever
so you're out on a good behavior for
like however long or it's just like not
that big of a crime but you still are
they're given a contract for you so well
one of our buddies explained that does
all that stuff and it's like say like
you only there for like say a few days
but they still get the $20,000 the
prison system to hold you up for a
couple of months what you mean so like
say you went to jail right and I'm
supposed to be like five years right but
you got out of a few months to get the
behavior they're still getting paid for
that five years that you're supposed to
be there oh they're still getting that
contract for that because it's like
you're not in the system you're learning
on the system and then now what's been
coming out is they're looking at all
those people with the small crimes that
they have to like look overnight or do
all that stuff it's whenever they look
at when these people came in everything
it's always within the last hour two
hour
half an hour of the cops or something
because then now because it's for them
they say it's way easier just to go down
to the precinct and follow some basic
paperwork but because they're there now
longer they gain time and a half because
of it yeah and on top of that that
person now has to stay overnight in the
jail system and they get another
contract for holding that person for the
time that they'll be there and they're
the the the jail or wherever they're at
and holding it they're getting thousands
of dollars even though the releasing
them tomorrow morning just because they
they went over the time and they have to
like stay there overnight or something
so it's like all these things and it's
like I get it with just regular times I
call it book booking like booking a
hotel so it's like when it when they
come out and like watch it like to read
the signs like a book yeah that's why
well how did this guy not know yeah oh
my gosh okay so this takes place in
Samoa okay oh he's probably like so
childlike this is dope like it's cool
bah bah wah wah wah is it I think so
okay so that okay I'm imagining their
jail is like a bunch of coconut trees as
the wall and then it's like nice on the
beach and you just chill and you play
football with other Samoan dudes and
there's giant cardboard cutouts I like
the rock yeah everywhere it's like the
complete their hardest [ __ ] out there
alright so apparently their prisons that
their criminal justice system is really
bad and like really faulty and so they
were saying that usually this happens
where people end up like serving their
time where they don't realize it but for
this particular specific story this man
so back in December 20 of 2008 he was
convicted on what the hell sorry the way
let me start over sorry sorry cuz the
freaking article I'm a tattoo you know
an ad popped up and I lost my spot okay
okay restart all right so this man he
was supposed to be released in December
2015 by the way but anyway the way that
he got into jail to be
once he was convicted of burglary and
theft in November of 2008 and he was
sentenced to seven years in prison then
in December of 2008 he was convicted on
unrelated counts of burglary and theft
and sentenced to five years in prison
then so then they're saying that those
sentences should have been concurrently
start knots consecutively oh and so
because of that he was supposed to be
released in December of 2015 but no one
told him anything he actually never knew
the entire length of his sentence he
just thought like well I did the crime I
gotta do the time so I'm just doing the
time so he he thought that like his
lawyer or someone would let him know
like oh you're talking everyone was bum
oh you gotta be responsible for your own
thing I guess that's one thing that like
sucks is no one's gonna have your best
interest in mind more than yourself yeah
so like even like just Peter he did this
interview about it and my man stuff he
goes you have to be your own head coach
at the end of the day you still hire and
fire your own head coach and when he
said that I'm like oh [ __ ] I related
that to like so many things I even
you're the own lawyer you're your first
lawyer before you hire your lawyer
everything you your own contract oh yeah
yeah everyone works for you you have to
be your own everything first I don't
know as much as you want someone else to
take the lead because it's so much
easier you have to stay on top of them
yeah yeah so the way that the error was
finally noticed was by okay so in just
say some oh okay they some wah listen I
don't know if you guys are trolling
mirror that's how you say it correctly
anyway no there is how okay so it's very
common that there's a lot of breakouts
of the prisons cuz they got coconut
cheese that you just go like this and
their biggest [ __ ] yeah I know those
guys could just probably run into a
[ __ ] wall and bust it open like the
kool-aid man
oh yeah use me awesome strongest class
ever I know
Samoan glass I think something and you
were just drinking his blood think about
that because that's like a common thing
he was in courts for an appearance over
an assault allegedly committed during a
mass break out of the prison he was in
and so during that apparent court
appearances when they were like five
years ago
oh damn at least someone's reading it
was for four years and eight months so
now they're looking into suing because
he was held he was being detained
illegally for four years in eight months
that's great I hope nothing bad happened
in the last five years he's like you
told me I could have avoided a but
raping but I'm [ __ ] stuck in this
moment damn lucky lady got raped three
years ago or something like some bad
stuff really like a home you could've
died like some really bad stuff could
happen those guys there whatever is your
telling that could avoid all that right
or like if something happened to his
family within that time yeah doing that
oh and he couldn't go to the funeral and
[ __ ] yeah or he just wasted five years
of his life plus missing a song
graduation of three so he's missed out
on his three kids lives for the last
four years and eight months he came out
and he's in 2020 shit's [ __ ] up he was
back inside yeah he's like [ __ ] 2020
I'm glad oh man I would have gladly had
like 2015 to 2019
yes 2020 in jail maybe I owe her too
yeah forty-five years old look at his
face he's like should have been forty
that face looks like you're telling me I
could have been out just like that [ __ ]
yeah that reminds me of the the one day
CS documentary in that story of the the
Central Park five from New York Norman
that yep well they just grew up watching
movies all day oh that one no that one
yeah
there was it that okay nevermind oh the
central that's the Wolfpack what is that
such a central part one so the director
Ava Duvernay Deborah knew the goofy I
don't know anyways yeah she she put
together when they see us which was a
documentary series on Netflix or
apostolic series and it was about these
five kids aged like 14 to 18 or
something like that that were caught up
in a central park like raping of this
white woman and notices for black isms
when it's back to do a thing and so the
prosecution immediately put the raping
and the sexual assault on them and these
miners went to jail for like a long time
but it wasn't them at all they were just
in the park at the same time just in the
park at the same time and it wasn't them
at all and and and clearly in the
prosecution the evidence like same thing
that you were talking about like there's
kids in these rooms with these cops and
these cops are just like sign this
things you did it and it that you did it
this person said that you did did yeah
and it's been proven that if you have an
IQ under like 98 something like that
it's more likely that you would admit to
guilt towards something that you haven't
done exactly so so they're coercing
these people there's no lawyers in there
there's no parents in some of those
situations you know what I mean and
obviously Ben being like you know
bipod in my situation they didn't even
have a translator for my mom for my
parents so they're supposed to have a
translator there and then so if you
think about it right there's a lot of
like Mexican kids that don't have
translators or Spanish speakers and it's
optional I don't know like shits going
down in our system that's [ __ ] up I
don't know about now but yeah I don't
know if now they do it more legit but
back then man like it was [ __ ] up dude
[Music]
[Music]